[Musique]
tout commence un jour de 1988
j'ai 26 ans et je n'ai absolument pas
envie d'aller jouer au golf
à cette époque je trouvais que c'était
un jeu pour les riches et que c'était
pas un sport du tout
j'avais envie d'être de pratiquer des
jeux ou des sports où j'étais beaucoup
plus engagé physiquement alors le golfe
non merci
pour autant pas pas un jour m'a fait un
cadeau m'a dit j'ai payé un cours va
prendre le cours s'est fait j'avais pas
envie j'ai été lors de ma première
expérience expérience j'ai touché
quelques balles fantastique et jean
devient tellement accro et passionné que
je découvre une nouvelle drogue
alternative j'ai bien dit une nouvelle
drogue alternative et je peux vous dire
beaucoup plus forte que toutes les
autres que je connaissais déjà à
l'époque j'étais toxicomane depuis
plusieurs années et j'ai essayé de m'en
sortir désespérément rien n'y faisait
grâce au golf
j'arrête l'héroïne quelques mois plus
tard ma vie change
je redécouvre les qui vibre et la joie
de vivre je trouve un emploi dans une
grande entreprise de restauration
française jean devient le directeur du
développement je joue au golf ou les
week-ends et je n'ai qu'une seule idée
passé professionnel de golf mais je n'en
trouve ni le courage ni les moyens
pas si simple lorsqu'en 1995 je suis
diagnostiqué d'un cancer
je décide d'écouter mon coeur et contre
vents et marées de me diriger vers ma
passion je change de vie bien soigné je
vais quitter mon poste de directeur et
membre et m'emmener directement vers le
golf alors à ce moment là tout le monde
arrive tous les briseurs de rêves ça ne
marchera jamais tu ne gagneras jamais ta
vie qu'est ce que tu vas faire comment
vas tu faire pour s'en sortir on ne peut
pas démarrer une carrière
professionnelle dans un jeu aussi
pointue
à 33 ans bref je vous passe toutes les
idées pour ne surtout pas que je fasse
ce changement de vie et bien quelques
années plus tard je suis bien devenu
professionnel de golf
aujourd'hui je suis coach pour les
joueurs de haut niveau sur le tour
européen
je suis formateur pour mes confrères et
rédacteur pour les magazines spécialisés
tout est possible quand on a décidé
d'écouter son coeur et je peux vous dire
que c'est juste fantastique
petite parenthèse c'est un un cancer
testicules et en mon honneur au lever 1
et finalement c'est peut-être ce qui m'a
donné le courage d'avoir les wii pour le
faire alors j'aimerais ce soir partager
avec vous l'utopie dans laquelle
l'utopie en voie de réalisation dans
laquelle je me suis engagé il y a
maintenant un peu plus d'une vingtaine
d'années mais ce qu'il faut savoir c'est
que tout est possible mais rien ne
serait arrivé de cette manière si je
n'avais pas rencontré un homme
absolument incroyablement extraordinaire
hors du commun qui s'appelle bill owens
bill owens est un professionnel de golf
gallois et je vais vous raconter une
partie de notre histoire ensemble parce
que pendant ma chimio évidemment je ne
sais pas quoi faire je ne sais pas où
aller je sais pas par quel bout
commencer
j'ai décidé de devenir pro de golf mais
où va-t-on je me dirige tout
naturellement vers mon pro deux clubs
kiné qui est bill owens et lorsque je
lui fais part de mes intentions
il me répond j'ai inventé une méthode
incroyable pour apprendre à jouer en
quelques heures et développer tous les
plaisirs de ce jeu en un temps record
alors que normalement il faut des années
pour apprendre à jouer
lui me dit en quelques minutes tu vas
voir c'est incroyable il murray puis il
enchérit en disant je sais qu'il faut
toute une vie pour très bien joué au
golf mais grâce à cette méthode
je vais changer la face du monde alors
là comme vous probablement maintenant où
certains d'entre vous probablement
maintenant je veux dit ce mec est
complètement fou et les frappadingues
comment on va pouvoir changer la face du
monde changer l'avenir de la planète
avec un jeu aussi et les tice que le
golf alors peut-être faut-il replacer le
dans un autre compte a expliqué il faut
le voir sous un autre angle
peut-être que c'est pas le golf que vous
pensez connaître peut-être que c'est pas
le plus grand polluants ou utilisateurs
de pesticides et utilisateurs d'eau que
vous pensez connaître peut-être que
c'est toute autre forme de golf eh ben
il poursuit en me disant un golf s'est
jamais qu'à un morceau de nature dans
lequel on va jouer depuis des départs
qui sont signalés par des repères de
couleur pour aller mettre la balle dans
un trou
signalé par un drapeau il suffit
d'utiliser n'importe quel espace naturel
et on peut faire des golfs partout j'ai
eu d'ailleurs la chance de venir en
train de paris à limoges
j'ai vu des golfs partons c'est génial
il ya des vaches des moutons qui font
l'entretien c'est super il suffit juste
de mettre des boules et un drapeau et ça
y est cette école et il continue en me
disant construire des golfs partout avec
cette méthode ou qui permet d'apprendre
à jouer très très vite donc construire
des golfs par tous pour que tout le
monde joue et arrête de se battre ça
c'est l'idée au l'or alors la deuxième
couche
la cabane tombe sur le chien je n'avais
absolument pas vu le golf de cette
manière là moi je voulais juste devenir
pro donner des cours changer de vie déjà
j'étais ravi mais alors là vous voyez
pas changer la planète
alors évidemment 95 va être l'année dans
laquelle je m'engage dans cette utopie
je trouvais son projet tellement
fascinant et ambitieux je suis parti
avec lui et pour aller démontrer le bien
fondé de son idée on est parti dans les
banlieues les plus défavorisés
c'est comme ça qu'on les appelle moi je
les trouve pas spécialement défavorisés
on en a fait une histoire mais c'est pas
le sujet et nous partons donner des
cours aux jeunes des banlieues mais pour
ça on est obligées d'aller donner des
cours le week-end pour faire un petit
peu d'argent pour donner bénévolement
notre temps aux jeunes des cités la
semaine nous écrivons au pouvoir
politique en disant nous avons une idée
qui permet de transformer certaines
choses et nous rencontrons des jeunes
absolument formidable et super
talentueux pendant ce temps mes parents
sont super inquiet et me surnomme l'abbé
pierre du golfe bill poursuivi en disant
une époque où les problèmes sont
parfaitement identifiés je crois qu'on
en a suffisamment pris connaissance et
pris conscience environnement violences
urbaines économie famine immigration d'y
être climat etc
enfin la liste est longue il faut qu on
trouvait qu'on mette en place une
solution globale il faut mettre en place
une solution globale qui pourrait régler
n'ont pas tous les problèmes mais un
petit peu de tous les problèmes
le golf peut présenter cette solution
globale à notre société
le golf a tellement de vertus diverses
et variées très méconnue par exemple
basiquement c'est un jeu et pas un sport
alors vous me direz bon à quelle
différence
vous allez voir le sport fait à des
bienfaits sur la santé sur la meilleure
une meilleure vie en collectivité une
meilleure solidarité une meilleur jeu
des équipes mais s'adresse qu'à des
sportifs ou à ceux qui voudraient bien
en faire si on gère un projet socio
éducatif par le jeu et non pas par le
sport on ouvre le spectre à tout le
monde sans exception
pas de discrimination face aux sports
jouer est probablement une des choses
les plus merveilleuses qu'on a oublié de
faire aujourd'hui qu'on commence à
oublier de fermer ça nous permet de
partager des règles de développer de la
camaraderie de booster la créativité et
l'émerveillement et pourquoi pas pour
tout le monde alors jouer à n'importe
quoi finalement parce que j'entends déjà
des jeux
de musique ou des joueurs de théâtre ou
des joueurs sur des gameboys des joueurs
de foot qui me disent oui mais n'importe
quel jeu parce que réinstaurer le sens
du jeu dans notre vie aujourd'hui est
essentiel parce que jouer c'est la colle
qui nous lient les uns avec les autres
et jouer au golf c'est le vecteur idéal
pour une éducation citoyenne et
environnementale
c'est le jeu parfait pour être connecté
avec la nature et moins avec son
smartphone même si moi aussi je passe
trop de temps sur mon smartphone mais
enfin c'est comme ça donc maintenant
l'idée est en faisant son chemin il me
dit forcément il faut mettre ça il faut
que nos futures générations puissent
grandir avec cette éducation par le jeu
il faut qu'on puisse transmettre à nos
enfants
donc le seul moyen de pouvoir
transmettre de manière sûre à nos
enfants c'est de mettre le golf à
l'école
vaste débat en 1996 il crée un nouveau
concept adapté à l'éducation qui
s'appelle golf éducatif est là avec le
golf éducatif on découvre un moyen un
outil pédagogique sécurisé pour
l'éducation
il se place à côté de l'instruction
civique dans tous les programmes
scolaires et dans toutes les écoles de
l'école primaire jusqu'à l'université
le golf éducatif nous aident à
transmettre les valeurs du jeu de golf
les valeurs du jeu en général mais de
golf plus particulièrement que sont le
respect
l'étiquette et l'humilité je pense que
ces trois valeurs méritent d'être
partagées à l'école sans négociation
possible le respect des règles
essentielles mais le respect de soi et
de l'autre et surtout le respect de la
nature
en ce qui concerne l'éthique est je vous
rassure on ne donne pas encore de
courbes de bon maintien de la fourchette
pour aller faire des dîners chics mais
plutôt les petites règles et les bonnes
manières pour bien se comporter sur un
parcours de golf qui sont facilement
transposables notre quotidien avec le
golf éducatif
on a un moyen de donner aux enfants aux
enseignants et aux seniors de la ville
la possibilité de planter des arbres
donc chaque semaine les enfants sont
impliqués dans la construction de leur
parcours ils deviennent responsables de
leurs de leur environnement ils
deviennent responsables et fiers de leur
propre acte et je crois que c'est
important aujourd'hui de pouvoir donner
à nos jeunes un moyen d'être fiers d'eux
mêmes alors une des particularités de ce
projet qui n'est plus un projet ce qu'il
est utilisé dans il sait sont des
milliers d'enfants qui jouent au golf
éducatif aujourd'hui mais une des
particularité c'est que nous avons
changé la balle la balle de golf est une
balle alléger on est en train de
réfléchir à utiliser les décharges de
plastique pour fabriquer cette balle
alléger on fera comme ça une
récupération intelligente de notre
environnement qui est un petit peu sa
cage et donc la balle vole trois fois
moins loin ce qui nous permet de rentrer
des golf éducatif dans n'importe quel
parc public en termes de sécurité il n'y
a aucun danger comme la balle et trois
fois plus légère et qu'elle vole trois
fois moins loin on joue sur des parcours
qui sont trois fois plus petit et donc
trois fois plus accessible en termes de
proximité aussi en termes de coûts nous
n'utilisons que des friches et des
jachères et des matériaux de
récupération autant vous dire que c'est
quasiment zéro alors finalement on se
pose nous la question depuis maintenant
1995 quel autre jeu quels autres moyens
quel autre idée pourrait-on avoir pour
avoir un développement aussi puissant
sur l'environnement sur l'éducation sur
le partage dans un contexte
intergénérationnel et d'économie
solidaire dans le respect de la mixité
et des différences de chacun on n'a pas
encore bien trouver je pense
qu'aujourd'hui on a une vraie solution
alternative ici pour sauver notre
planète
ah parce que lorsque j'entends monsieur
macron le mois dernier à paris d'hier
pour les problèmes climatiques
on a pas de planète b je dois dire que
c'est carrément flippant est très
préoccupant mais qu'allons nous laisser
à nos futures générations si on ne fait
qu'être préoccupé sans rien faire pour
changer quelque chose
mettre le golf éducatif à l'école s'est
donné les moyens à nos enfants pour que
nous puissions ensemble nous aider à
construire un monde meilleur
c'est un moyen de partager la richesse
si nous en mettant le golf éducatif à
l'école prochaine rentrée scolaire ce
sont 12 millions de scolariser qui vont
pouvoir planter des arbres réhaussé une
partie de notre économie et devenir des
bons citoyens
combien d'autres dans le monde imaginez
à l'exemple d'un si la france
on sait est toujours suivie dans tous
ces exemples administratif
cette idée sort de france l'europe va
reprendre toute cette idée combien de
millions d'enfants combien d'arbres et
de plantes et dans ce projet là c'est
massif parce que c'est bien de ça qu'il
s'agit faire jouer tout le monde
souvenez vous c'est l'objectif et le
rêve initial certes c'est un doux rêve
mais quand on regarde le travail
accompli depuis 1995 ce doux rêve prend
une vraie autre tournure
le mois dernier le golf éducatif a été
primé comme meilleur projet de
développement par l'association
européenne des golfeurs professionnels
qui regroupe 34 pays et 21000
professionnel de golf
bill est enfin reconnu il y à une
vingtaine de golf éducatif en france une
vingtaine de villes impliquées
il reste beaucoup de travail encore
évidemment mais se sont d'ores et déjà
des milliers d'enfants qui chaque
semaine joue à partager les règles de
notre monde de demain alors si c'était
ça le déclic tant attendu pour une
solution globale mise en place par nos
institutions et nos hommes politiques
demain en attendant continuons à rêver
et ensemble par ton jouet planter des
arbres partager et faisant de notre
planète
le plus beau terrain de jeu éducatif
merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]